good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Friday I don't feel
like singing today even though I'm
really glad it's Friday I've never
needed a weekend more um hey guys I'm
back sorry for missing yesterday's
episode I I was planning on doing it
like I was fully dressed me too it was
just at the 11th Hour that but the day
took such a turn
um so there was no episode yesterday
because my worst nightmare came true and
Theo left us yesterday I can't believe
I'm saying
that
um how are
you I'm okay like I'm going through like
highs and lows like I cried on the
toilet this morning but then I was fine
for the rest of the day it just keeps
hitting me in different ways and like
weird things and you know I'm trying to
avoid like all pictures but he's just
everywhere cuz that's like where he was
you
know um and he's everywhere at the
studio for sure so he I'm okay um I do
do feel like I've been slowly mourning
Theo since we found out the news like I
knew this day was going to come so I
don't it doesn't feel as fresh but um
the actual like experience of like
putting a dog down which I had never
done was so
hard and I just remember like wanting to
get it over with basically what happened
is like the last like two days he was
just like like in bad shape and I was
really ignoring a lot of it but when we
woke up yesterday morning it was just
like unignorable we woke up and I was
like what is that smell and like my
entire bedroom was covered in vomit and
poop and Theo got in bed with us and
just started vomiting in his sleep and
so Ben and I just like looked at each
other and we were like we had a doctor's
appointment for like acupuncture at
11:00 and I called the place um and I
was like can we come in earlier to see
like a regular doctor and also like do
you guys I didn't know like you have to
ask do you guys do that do you euthanize
and they were like yes come in
immediately so we went to your vetare on
the Upper East Side and they were really
amazing
and it was just like a pretty place you
know it's like very cute and blue and as
sad as it was I felt like when we were
told to put him down two weeks ago at
the hospital like the hospital was so
depressing yeah and and I just don't
think that was like a good place for
Theo to
go and I think this place like it was
just like prettier and everyone was so
nice and I have no like the only thing
that brought me peace and that continues
to be me pieces I know I did the right
thing of course like his time was up and
I felt like I kept him home and I kept
him comfortable for as long as I could
but I don't think he was comfortable
anymore and that's not fair and it just
like dawned on me that we've been like
you know weekend a Bering him a little
bit which is exactly what I said I
didn't want to do like he was only
eating because we were giving him an
appetite stimulant he wasn't walking he
was only [__] because we were giving
him laxatives he was wearing diapers
like it's not a way to live for sure but
when you first set out to do that it was
just to get him into treatment so that
then he could go on to live life but I
think it was becoming clear that like it
would always be like this and that's
when you've decided to make the decision
so yeah we were just thinking like okay
yeah radiation might work but it
probably won't and even if it does I
it's not going to give him much more
time and given the rate that things were
going it wasn't making him more
comfortable right so I know I did the
right thing and when I walked in there
like we weren't sure what we were going
to do but we we left the house and we
were like this is a real possibility so
we need to just like start thinking that
way and when I walked out of the house
I'm carrying the and we're walking
across the street and it's snowing and I
texted you and I was like oh my God it's
snowing like what does that mean I
wasn't sure if it was a a sign like to
keep going or that this was the end like
I wasn't sure but I knew it meant
something and you said I was like it's
snowing what does it mean and you said
it means that Theo got to see the snow
before Christmas and that really in that
moment like I knew I knew what we were
going to do
um so we did and then and then when you
left it was no longer swing s yeah no
like I I know I made the right decision
and that's like the only thing that
brings me peace like I have no regrets
about how the whole situation
unfolded so he got to come home and he
got to be with us and he I got more time
with him and he got more time with us
but towards like the last 2 three days
like he wasn't there like I don't even
think he knew where he was like so I
know I made the right decision and
that's that brings me peace yeah and I
do think the last few weeks he was in
heaven with you guys in bed watching
Gossip Girl yeah eating everything he
finally got to eat whatever he wanted he
had an Insomnia Cookie like he was
living life it was so hard like he got
to see the tree he got to be in a
stroller yeah no it's it's true and
there's just like so many questions they
ask you like I don't know you know like
what like first of all what do you want
to do with the remains and they like
brought me this like list of options and
I literally called my Rabbi cuz I'm like
we don't do this like cremating and he
was like you know there's nothing in the
halaka about like pet remains like do
whatever you want whatever makes you
happy I I don't know just like cremation
is so inherently not Jewish and I just I
wasn't pulled to that at all so I Didn't
Do It um and then also like do you want
to be in the room and I didn't want to
and Ben was like I don't want Theo to be
alone and the doctor his name was Dr
Mendes he was he had the best
disposition like of all the doctors I've
seen this entire Journey like he was he
made me feel so much better like having
bedside manner is so important like it
really is and he was so smart and he was
just
like this is this is what I did with my
dog this is what other people do like he
was just very level-headed about the
whole situation and he was like really
gentle with Theo so we ended up staying
in the room there's basically like two
things that they
do to put a dog down the first is like
they give them human grade anesthetic
and the doctor was like up until that
point like he'll be able to see and hear
you but once we put this in like he's
completely
unconscious and then they do the second
drug which is you know the final nail in
the coffin if you will um so we we
stayed for him to get the anesthetic and
his eyes just completely glazed over and
his stomach like wasn't moving and I was
like okay that like that was enough for
me it like freaked me out a little bit
um and so we left and I just I really
wanted to get it over with like I kept
wishing Theo would just like take his
own last breath so I didn't have to be
the one to make the decision cuz it's so
sad it's so sad and it's really hard
it's a hard choice to make yeah but I
know I made the right decision like I
keep saying that cuz I know I did yeah
and I just kept thinking like I've just
been like when we got home there was
like already like Bagels flowers food
like everything and I know that there
are people who like you know put their
dogs down and their dogs are their whole
life and they don't have other people
around around them and so I'm just
trying to like really focus on how lucky
we are to have given him like the best
care I could have given like I literally
spent every dollar I had to keep him
comfortable like the fact that I was
able to do that I'm so lucky the fact
that I have people in my life who care
about me who cared about Theo people who
met him people who didn't meet him like
literally like reading the comments on
my Instagram like made me cry but it's
just like thousands of people who can
say that he touched thousands of people
and not everyone can say that so I'm
really just trying to focus on how
really lucky I am and just
like not focus on like the last couple
of months but really focus on like
Theo's whole life
like I think people are like why are you
guys so obsessed with Cavaliers and we
had one growing
up and when our parents got divorced we
um we like lost the dog and the divorce
and then our dad passed away and so like
we really never got closure with the
childhood dog that we loved so much and
years later whenever I would see like a
Cavalier on the street it would just
like it means so much to me and it was
like so much Nostalgia and like our
childhood and I remember when I was
getting married I like realized that I
have free will and I'm like an adult and
I can do stuff so I got a Cavalier and
it was like this thing I always wanted
my whole life and that was
Theo and I did it like it made me so
happy and it made our whole family so
happy and we got Bruno and we got
Magnolia and like he just started this
whole love affair for our family and he
like I know he like he served his
purpose
and I wish I got more time and I do feel
really robbed to have only gotten six
years it's so unfair and I'm really
trying not to like enter that stage of
grief where I'm just angry cuz like it's
so
unfair but it's
okay I want to get another dog my house
feel sad when we got home we just like
immediately got rid of everything
because like Theo was I he was always
everywhere but especially in like the
recent weeks he required so many more
things like meds and diapers and I just
threw it all out because if I had to see
it I know it would like really trigger
me um so I'm okay like I I really I am
okay you do seem measured like
and obviously sad sad not a basket case
even though you have every right to be
when I'm distracted like I really can't
be on my phone cuz people are being so
nice but like it's really like it's
making me I'm sure it's a lot even I'm
getting so many messages and I'm just an
anty so
like I'm okay I really am like as long
as I'm distracted like I'm fine well
that's what the toast does distracts but
I do also feel like we have to honor our
he he's the third co-host everyone says
who would be the co-host if one of you
dropped out like would have been Theo no
he came to work every day he showed up
to work every day with a smile on his
face yeah no we built this brand like
off of Theo's back Theo was there for
you in the cancellation no he really was
by the way like when I think about how
many things I've been through like with
Theo he was so receptive to like my
emotions like he always knew when to
behave and like he was really I I
remember him being like so emotionally
supportive for me when I got cancelled
like Theo's been with me through so much
through highs and lows and you know what
when he went out on a high and he went
out on a high I didn't like I I don't
like I do need
him but like I don't need him right now
you know he got you to a great place
yeah where like I'm really happy I was
like in the tub yesterday I can't get
like the tub is really depressing for me
but like I was really smelly like
covered in poop and I got out and I was
just like looking at myself in the
mirror and I'm like so mad at myself cuz
I finally feel like I'm at like a really
good like physically healthy place where
I can do more with Theo like Ben was
always the one like do doing the
physical stuff like I was the bed mom
and the Ben was the the the walk mom dad
and I like feel so guilty that like I
finally got to a place where like I can
do more things with him and like now I
can't even do them well on the other
side of it he also is a lap dog and most
of most parts of him just wanted to lay
in bed with his mama all day and his
mama provided the comfiest bed the best
television yeah the best
scratchies I'm okay I just honestly like
I can't listen to music I find it so
triggering I understand that like love
you anyway by Luke Holmes like seriously
oh you brige you have to boycott the
whole album yeah cuz you know
what this one's for
D he's so part of the lore every part of
how I speak is dcoded I know I do think
the timing is like good I need a few
days so like it being the weekend is
really helpful but then also like our
end of year break coming up like I need
some time and I'm I'm excited we're all
going away together and I can like be
with other people um and then I will I
will get another dog like for real I'm
excited me too we'll look to the
Future that's what you would want for
you I
know I know so I'm okay I really am
because it's it's not so fresh in the
sense I don't feel like day one it feels
like day 14 yeah and it's it right as it
is you had like time to come around to
the idea as much as you could and
prepare yourself as much as you could
yeah but still it's I don't know
yesterday was like so different it felt
so different like when you said that you
were really think like it really hadn't
hit me I've just been in denial me too
what you know what I was actually
getting a manicure I got a turdy cure I
got the tury special you know what song
was playing when it was his time on in
the salon M when you believe pentatonics
version
oh my God chills cuz you know what song
was was playing at the vet they were
like you can take as much time you as
you need and just let us know when
you're ready and so when we were taking
that time it was so depressing Stay With
Me by Sam Smith and like oh won't you oh
yeah it was they should carate the
playlist a little better just
saying I was like you're kidding me they
need Kelly Clarkson yeah they need to
keep Christmas tunes Christmas tunes I
cracked out the Christmas playlist last
night yeah so music is like a very
sensitive point for me I will not be
listening even though I think I'm going
to go to a concert tonight I just like
whenever I'm doing stuff I am okay what
concert um it's Jingle Ball so it's like
a medley of concerts oh and Olivia
Rodrigo's playing and Ben wants to go
and and I think I think I should Olivia
classic yeah that'll be fun yeah no I
the two of you no I'm going to go with a
couple people snitch the tailor you know
who goes to Jingle Ball every year year
andbe Dana does she she loves Jingle
Ball oh my God I'm going to text her
Jingle Ball is so Middle School coded
like Dana is Middle School Dana is stuck
in a Time Warp where she's a middle
schooler going through life as a 31y old
woman no that's so true it's I literally
knew what you were going to say like I I
that's so funny she doesn't miss a year
of Jingle Bell she doesn't make a big
thing of it I wouldn't be surprised if
she goes by herself sometimes well you
know what I'm glad I'm going then so she
has someone to go with she would love an
invite okay I'll text her that's so
funny okay so you're just like teeny
bopping your way through life tonight
yeah I just want to be distracted and
that's what I will be doing that's what
we will be doing today on to how are you
doing I know do meant a lot to you do
meant so much to
me but I don't want to make it about me
no you can it's okay like I like it
makes me feel good that like so many
people like loved this thing that I
brought to them you know it's just there
was a time when he was my first and only
nibling I know and he taught me how to
be an auntie and I remember when Kayla
was being born and Theo was the only
other nibbling and I was like I don't
know how I could love a baby more than I
love Theo I know but he expanded my
heart and showed me how to be an auntie
and made me a proud Auntie yeah and
really like I mean you didn't become an
auntie until after until Kayla but
it's been such a blessing and when he
used to stay by me and I used to watch
this pause after every single walk CU
that was a nutcase and that one time I
gave him a whole bath so he could sleep
in bed with me and watch Yellowstone and
then you came and picked him up yeah um
when I wanted him to stay I remember and
we
just so many good so many good times
such a sweet Soul it's so crazy like the
last time him and brood were together if
you had told me this is the last time
they would be that would have been like
in right before I came back to Florida
mhm I wouldn't I would be like what I
know it's the craziest thing it's the
craziest
thing and I have my D pillow that I'm
looking at I'm not getting rid of it the
Brew pillow is like actually really
triggering me know I have to like keep
Brew off of FaceTime like Bruno go in
the
corner Brew not now Bruno go go hide
from Auntie it's not your time but no
Bruno is Bruno's grieving um I know and
also it's like all the kids love Theo I
know Michaela loves Theo Harry loves fa
like do we tell them no Harry I don't I
think he's young enough that he won't
realize let's see what happens next time
we're at your apartment like if he's
asking but right now he doesn't like ask
for fa so he might
forget I I wouldn't tell him anything I
just be like who what where when why gas
gasl the [__] and then you'll have a new
dog and be like it's f f yeah and since
it's a nickname it's fine yeah I I
really want to get on getting another
dog like my house feels
meaningless empty quiet I got rid of
everything except the crate I do think I
like I'm going to get I know I'm going
to get another dog so you should yeah
boy or girl boy boy Mama
yeah great well we will never stop
talking about do we couldn't if we tried
here the fast story is that you do like
everything is coded yeah so I'm really
looking forward to like talking about
anything else okay I'm on it because we
didn't do a show yesterday which I
apologize for we hopefully have lots of
good stories worth discussing I thought
like double the stories double the fun
no no still pretty much crap but it will
be a great show that's what do would
want not to keep bringing him up um cuz
we are going to distract act but it's
also Hanukkah it is last night was the
first night of Hanukkah which also felt
meaningful meaningful in some way was a
light yeah definitely and he shined
bright so I thought that was meaningful
too not there's no coincidences no no
there's not so happy Hanukkah to
everyone who celebrates I hope that you
had a great first night getting good
gifts giving good
gifts happy Hanukkah to you tury thank
you happy Hanukkah to you as
well publicize the nice everyone but now
that I live in an apartment that's not a
bunker I can publicize the Nace
beautiful beautiful okay so without
further ad oh I just wanted to say one
more thing of course there were like so
many people I wanted to tell you know um
that Theo was no longer with us um cuz
Theo kind of had like a a big Social
Circle he did and
so many just like one thing in
particular like really broke me I sent
it to you guys um you know Theo's dog
walking career was such an integral part
of his day and he loved it so much and
he loved Jonathan who was the actual
Walker along with the crew butter
mystery olives so I'd been keeping him
updated because Theo obviously wasn't
going on the walks recently and I texted
him yesterday just letting him know like
Theo is no longer with us and he was
really upset
um and he said it was his pleasure to be
let me just read it because I don't want
to butcher it it was so
sweet heartbreaking news it was my
pleasure to be his friend and Walker and
that really made me upset cuz Theo loved
him so much those were definitely the
highlights of his day
totally I hope Butters is
okay I don't I'm
kidding I'm totally kidding
I'm just like jealous like when I like
when I see like I'm in my bitter
resentful stage okay that means you're
traveling through the grief no like
whenever I see someone's dog on the
street I just want to go up to the owner
and shake them like don't take his
health for granted well you'll be glad
to know as we speak Bruno is at the vet
oh good good good good CU I also there
were so many people who were so helpful
and like I will think all of them
properly but one of them was Theo's vet
his whole life Dr Lisa who has just been
like of course checking in but then also
helping us find different special and
whatever and she's going to um text you
about what sort of screenings cuz
hopefully this isn't genetic but if it
is you know they're all from the same
breeder and it might be an issue down
the line different cancer no you're not
screwed because you have the one thing I
didn't have which was like knowledge and
preparation yeah and she's going to text
you about different things that you and
Margo should be doing and screening for
there's a lot of really good like cancer
screenings for dogs okay well he's there
as we speak good good take your dogs to
the vets yeah and the one thing I've
learned that I would like to pass on and
this is what I was saying to Ben this
whole thing started because Theo like
wasn't jumping up and it appeared like
he had some leg pain and to me I was
just like that's so okay like What's
worst case scenario his leg is broken
okay we'll put him in a cast like I
thought it was so um innocuous innocuous
I didn't know that like a limp is really
the first sign of something bad like
it's more often than not a tumor or a
mass or an obstruction of some sort like
I didn't know that I thought it was like
oh his to is broken being
lazy I really didn't know that it was
like an initial sign of something bad so
don't be Cavalier for lack of a better
word about it thank you I think a lot of
people are like Do's memory he's an
educator as well because he was a doctor
don't forget he was a doctor and he's a
public figure and he's leaving behind
lessons for everyone else yeah Dr
Theodor
fan
rip rip Theo rip I can't believe I'd be
saying that about Theo but no I said to
you yesterday like not to you but like
when his time came like rest in peace my
sweet angel and like I meant every word
of of rip what of the acronym I meant
every but I the thing is I didn't say
rip no cuz you have respect for the dad
right like rest in peace it's a lovely
saying to say that's all you could wish
for anyone to rest in peace yeah why you
got to say rip why you gotta be so
rip oh do we have a story about rip
today we actually don't but I just that
would have been a yesterday's story and
I'm gonna put it in because yeah there's
like some drama with rip from
Yellowstone and the creator of
Yellowstone Yellowstone is just falling
apart at the scat no the wheels are
coming off of Yellowstone and I'm adding
that because I had one story I didn't
particularly care about so that's
perfect great so while you do that why
don't I do my thing without further ad
Doo
about do we will remain do strong
forever don't get it twisted here are
the fast five stories that you do need
to know the fast five stories that you
need to know are brought to you by
drizzly drizzly is here to help you find
the right drink for the moment though
through its unmatched selection and
helpful recommendations so whether it's
your go-to favorite or something new
drizzly is here to help from holiday
cocktail Staples to new seasonal flavors
find all your holiday drinks on drizzly
the go-to app to get drinks delivered
especially during the holidays they
offer one of the widest selections of
beer Wine and Spirits available and in
some states sprit Society you can shop
their curated gift guides get
recommendations from experts and
discover drinks for all your holiday
festivities delivered right to your door
with drizzly you can compare prices on
drinks from local stores to save time
and money while shopping drizzly is so
easy like whether you're having people
over and you forgot to get stuff or you
told your husband to get it and he did
not get it drizzly oh are you going
somewhere and you forgot to bring a gift
and you don't want to show up looking
like a slob you can have drizzly deliver
it to your door or directly to the door
of the person whom you're going to see
just making you look like a nice lady
this holiday season even if you're not
so download the drizzly app or go to
drizzle.com it's the goto app for
alcohol delivery you must be over 21
it's not available in all locations
drizzly is just saving you time money
energy and like shame this holiday
season because what's more embarrassing
than being invited to a holiday party
and forgetting to bring something not
with drizzly just have the app
downloaded on your phone and you will
always be a nice gal and a good guest
who gets invited back yeah drizzle is
ensuring you're getting invited back
next year
so shop all your favorite drinks on
drizzly this holiday season today's
episode is also brought to you by State
Farm the State Farm personal price plan
helps you create an affordable price
just for you the plan is all about being
personal to you and your needs and that
means you're going to get the coverage
you want a policy that helps cover
what's important to you and an
affordable price just for you CU after
all life is just better when you can
personalize your experiences so think
about it like this from your go-to
coffee order to your favorite pair of
sweatpants we know you love to
personalize your entire day just like we
do I mean everything is so personal and
that's kind of one of the core tenants
here at the toast comedy is personal
food is personal breakfast tacos are
personal whether you like them enormous
like Jackie or teeny tiny like me
clearly personalization just makes
everything that much better State Farm
believes Insurance should work the same
way your plan your coverage and your
selections can all be personalized to
you I mean take example of Jackie and I
we are so similar we finish each other's
sandwiches yet our insurance needs
couldn't be more different we finish
each other's breakfast tacos we do
Jackie you know has dependence Jackie is
a homeowner Jackie lives in a different
state there are different needs you know
for me I don't have a lot of needs
especially now that I lost my one
dependent but you still have your car I
do still have my car that's brings me
great Solace during times like this
that's what I'm here for like a good
neighbor State Farm is there prices vary
by state options selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary ja
you want to sing us out like a good
neighbor stay farm and there wow you're
really not feeling like were you about
to saying I was going to say like a good
neighbor turty is there that's true too
today's four like a good tury stay firm
is there that's better today's episode
is also brought to you by Quin we loved
giftgiving but it can really add up and
that's why this holiday season we are
shopping at Quin our go-to for luxury
Essentials at affordable prices for
everyone on our list including me I have
to say Quince is probably the uh sponsor
we get the most questions about being
like what was that company again Quin
yeah my gorgeous cashmere sweater that
I've now had for 2 years and looks brand
new Quint my stunning slacks that make
me look like a real businesswoman Quint
they offer a range of high quality items
with prices Within Reach like 100%
Mongolian Kashmir sweaters from just $50
to washable silk tops tops and dresses
cotton sweaters and comfy pants the best
part that is that quin's items are all
priced 50 to 80% less than similar
Brands so that's why we're giving the
gift of quin's buttery soft cashmere to
our nearest and dearest friends this
year by partnering directly with top
factories Quin can cut out the cost of
the middleman and they pass the savings
on to you so you're getting that high
quality that good luxury but you're
paying a normal price Quin only works
with factories that use safe ethical and
responsible manufacturing practices and
premium fabrics and finishes we love
that I have so many items from quinc
that I love that are staple in my
wardrobe I really love their Kashmere
sweaters they're really stylish they're
really wellmade and I also love these
like black slacks that I got that are
really just like Timeless pants that
everyone needs so get affordable luxury
for everyone on your list with Quints go
to quinn.com
toast for free shipping on your order
and 365 day returns that's qu
nc.com toast to get free shipping and
365 day returns quinn.com
toast thank you la you're welcome our
first story Selena
gz go has a new mans she's making it
everyone's problem so she appears to
confirm that she's dating Benny Blanco
she said he is my absolute everything
amongst other things so AEL fan account
posted a photo of Selena and Benny
Blanco who was a music producer and she
said he is my absolute everything in my
heart and then she started replying to
some fans who I guess were right like
the news here for me is not that Selena
has a new man good for her who cares the
behavior in which she behaved last night
on social media was so deeply unhinged
and unwell and then she of course after
like you know setting the whole thing
comment section a break then she said
I'm getting off Instagram until my next
project and then what 25 minutes later
she's re-sharing like Wizards of Waverly
play stuff on her stories and wishing
Ashley Benson a mlto on her baby like I
don't know what's going on but somebody
has to take her phone away yeah so she
said he's absolutely everything in my
heart also the idea that like she's
commenting on Selena fan accounts and
with like breaking news no this just
isn't the behavior of the world's
biggest pop star billionaire Queen like
what are you doing yeah then she started
replying to to people saying I don't
know what their comments were but this
their comments people were like people
are not happy that she's dating him he
had been quoted like 6 years ago cuz he
produced the song Lonely with Justin
Bieber he had like said something in an
interview while promoting the song that
like you know she was a cookie cutter
pop queen who just makes makeup or
something like he has been you know
Shady in the past okay so this is she
said to one fan then why has he been the
best thing that's ever happened to me
the end and then to another fan yeah and
he's still better than anyone ever been
with facts and then to another fan I
don't understand if you actually care
about me this is my happiest if you
don't feel free to say whatever you want
but I will never allow your words to
guide my life ever I'm done if you can't
accept me at my happiest then don't be
in my life at all so I feel like this is
really um like emblematic of fan culture
and how you should always be grateful
for your fans or and and you know be
thanking them and whatever but when you
like start to get in the weeds and
like becoming so accessible I I don't
know I think I think this is dangerous
but it doesn't sound like she's talking
to
like fans I don't know people who are
commenting on like Selena fandages those
are Selena
fans I don't know I think they've just
like gotten sucked in to this gelina
stand culture they don't even know where
they what they believe anymore and if if
they are gelina stands not Selena stands
then Selena being with someone else goes
against their gelina core tenants it
goes against their constitution right
it's just like how they treat Justin
when he's with Haley it's how they treat
Selena when she has a new man it's
actually really toxic she can't move on
the jelina stands won't let her move on
either yeah
yeah but it's just like this vicious
cycle of Selena Gomez like remember when
she made like the war in Gaza about her
like she really has very bad social
media practices and I I think she's one
of these people who clearly runs her own
social media and probably shouldn't no
but she's one of these people who
actually doesn't run her own social
media I feel but you can tell when she
got her phone back oh oh that's actually
Fair the things that's posted on her
grid are like pretty curated and you
know not too much detail just a little
drop but she's also like the most
followed woman on Instagram so she's got
to give the people something yeah and
then every few weeks she like steals her
phone and you could tell Selena's back
yeah yeah um what a weird series of
events A Series of Unfortunate Events
the comments are just beyond strange and
it's just not how someone as famous as
Selena Gomez should be acting publicly
agreed let's talk about the coupling
yeah like whatever do you think like he
could be the one
no like I don't know I I don't find
Selena's dating life
like I don't I I do find Selena's dating
life very interesting and I I just think
this is like a fling and maybe we
wouldn't even be talking about it if it
weren't for these insane comments even
though she's the happiest she's ever
been he's better than anyone she's ever
been with facts well every time you're
with someone new you should feel that
way right otherwise like go back to the
other person that made you happier right
otherwise it's like it's not worth
pursuing yeah true fact no I don't think
that hopefully they make some music
together cuz he's you know obviously one
of the greatest producers of our time
is he yeah he's like he's done
everything yeah his name is so familiar
I actually thought he was an artist
himself he might like a singer let's see
if he has Spotify I actually no I don't
think that he is he's just no he's on
every popular song of the last 20 years
that's great he's major yeah he is Major
no like everything is like with yeah
yeah yeah he's always collabing he he I
think he was a main character on that
show
Dave because he looks like
him no he played
himself but Dave
is what's that little Dicky he looks
like him they both just have curly hair
and I believe they're both Jewish so he
wasn't a stunt double no he's four feet
tall okay
well congrats to the happy couple stay
off
Instagram period period are you ready
for next No Cap no no sorry that wasn't
how you use cap sorry no no cap
is no that was right say off Instagram
No Cap say off Instagram
bet the way that I feel about using cap
is like not the right way because I
would want to say stay off Instagram cap
like period no no I know I know put a
lid on it no for sure I kind of like
that I just want to say like everybody's
making up arbitrary definitions to these
words like they're not really rooted not
like coming from Latin so why can't I
make my own [__] up too fine
cap stay off Instagram cap well why you
put in like a question mark at I
know I um I undermind myself you mean
when you say cap like put a lid on it
like done period yes thank you I kind of
like that definition like like a
physical cap we're going to put a cap on
that we're done twist it put it away
throw it up give birth to it put it in a
blank
and then put a cap on that and put it
away and we're
done cap
period our next story is a little more
romantic news Okay Kevin Cosner and juel
have sparked dating rumors with cozy
pics after his divorce and Luan deeps is
crying tears of
sadness I was going to say something
rude but I'm not going to say it no it's
mean
and it's not what you would think okay
but I just want to say it should have
been Lan but I feel like it still could
be Lan yeah Lan and juel are not that
different no and also I wouldn't want to
be the woman right after the long-term
marriage divorce like so true luan's
waiting in the wings yeah no this one's
clearly a rebound and Luan is OTP L is
the final destination agreed also like
her response when someone asked like who
would you on a date and she said Kevin
cner like I feel like he's not
what people typically say you know
everyone's like Brad Pit Geor K but like
he's up he's just as great as those guys
no and the fact that I know we're joking
but he's and like might be dating juwel
is so age appropriate and he obviously
he could have and he might have done
like an 18-year-old like disgusting like
everyone else in Hollywood but he's
really I know we we talk [__] because
he's like ruining Yellowstone and I
think he's probably one of the meanest
people on the planet like if I had to
yes he's a family man he's respectable
you know dating someone of a certain age
and the bar is so low for men in
Hollywood that I have respect for this
so Kevin Cosner spark romance rumors
with Jewel when TMZ obtained photos of
her speaking into a microphone as Kevin
wrapped his arms around her waist the
duo were in the British Virgin Islands
for a week last month as part of a
tennis fundraiser for Jewels inspiring
children Foundation there was definitely
something going on as source told the
outlet they were flirty and when they
were together it was like they both just
lit up okay I want to see something
crazy controversial
SE like in my mind juwel and Cheryl Crow
are the same person okay for me
it's yeah it's juwel Cheryl Crow like
Leanne Rhymes Leanne
wac okay no so for me Leanne rymes is in
her own category because of Brandy
Glanville right that's the only reason
why she like breaks through and Leanne
wac like I don't even know what she
looks like physically I just know she
sings that song from Love is BL
[Laughter]
so like I I really like juwel and Sherl
Crow these like '90s guitar blonde gals
like they're just the same to me I know
but Cheryl Crow like is a little more
distinct to me because she's more
country no she just has like more
pervasive hits yeah I agree what does
juel sing really good songs let me find
them like I don't know Jewel and you
know we should look at related artists
because like those are also the people
yeah that I lump in the same group and
I'm sure for some like ju Stans this is
absolute blasphemy and like I respect
that it's just my experience that's my
opinion okay um like none of her top
five songs are
resonating
okay but I do think she was also a
little bit like at her Peak before our
time agreed but like we know Cheryl Crow
songs what's like Cheryl's Crow
I'm going to soak up the sun and also
what's that one with um kid that's like
it's like a classic karaoke song sing it
look at this Photograph are you kidding
me no that's nickel back are you okay no
no no oh all I want to do is have some
fun yeah but no what's the one with with
if it makes you happy but that's still
not the one what's the classic karaoke
song with Kid Rock and Cheryl Crow I
don't know but then the other Crow song
is one about
God sing
it
picture picture I put you picture with I
just want to say me saying photograph
when it's actually picture oh oh yeah
I'm not losing my mind no you're not and
honestly I think we need to start
putting more respect on Cheryl Crow's
name I never think about her as like a
musical influence of mine but I think
she might be okay and I have another
crazy thing to say about Cheryl Crow
what's the song about God God like how
God is like on the subway no if God
something about the bus it's like a
classic song God on the bus like yeah
wait no wait hold on don't tell me if
God were
a I I'm trying to find it cherl Crow God
song no no like if God were on a man
yeah no and if God were like on the
subway with me no on the bus if God were
on the bus it's like a classic I feel
like song Like A Hymn almost that she
recorded hold on this is infuriating
yeah wait hold on I'm gonna find it
Cheryl Crow all the
hits the First Cut is the Deepest Cheryl
Crow God bus song Claudia I already
searched that you did yeah no what's
this what if God was one of us
just the bus wow why was that so hard to
find okay but also I don't know if
Cheryl did that song cuz I looked it up
and it's a woman named Joan Osborne but
why do we both think Sher Crow sing the
song what if God was one of us one of us
is a song written by Eric Brazilian
performed by Joan Osborne not Cheryl
Crowe alannis moriset has also been
incorrectly been rumored to be the
singer of this song but she never
recorded it Joan Osborne did you know
who Cheryl Crow
also similar too but you have to just
zoom out of the situation who like think
of if an alien came down to earth and
these two women were standing next to
each other like they would think they
were twins who cheral Crowe and Sarah
Jessica
Parker oh physically yeah but not
career-wise no not career-wise but like
you know if SJP was having a bad day
like Cheryl Crow could play Carrie
Bradshaw yeah yeah is what I'm
saying
yeah so what was the story oh so juwel
is dating like love love hopefully he'll
become so happy with her he'll want to
get back to [__] work yeah well if
you goes back to work it might be a
toxic work environment because our be H
it's going to be hostile is that
Yellowstone Creator Taylor Sheridan has
sued Cole Houser's Coffee Company a
legal battle is brewing between the
creator of Yellowstone and one of its
Stars so Taylor Sheridan is the
showrunner Cole Hower is rip and Taylor
Sheridan's BOS Ranch filed a lawsuit
against rips Coffee Company free rign in
the Northern District of Texas on
November 21st in the court filing
obtained by people it accuses free reign
of trademark infringement unfair
competition and false advertising noting
that both companies use branding marks
with two overlapping letters letters the
lawsuit alleges neither Hower nor the
defendants asked to receive permission
or authorization of Sheridan or boss
grants choose a mark confusingly similar
to the BR brand for virtually identical
Goods people reached out to free reign
for comment Wednesday but did not
receive an immediate response so Taylor
Sheridan company is also coffee I guess
so it's called boss granch craft coffee
I want to say I'm I will defend rip till
the day I rip however the logos are
extremely similar yeah that's kind of
weird I thought at first that the
lawsuit was going to be like kle Houser
is kind of marketing his character of
Yellowstone which was written by Taylor
Sheridan you know like that would be a
stretch this is weird and like why
coffee it's weird because I feel like
it's very easy to make Taylor Sheridan
the um the villain but honestly I kind
of feel him in a legal sense like I
might do the same thing no this is weird
like the fact that he did a coffee when
Taylor Sheridan has a coffee is a little
like just unnecessary but then the logos
like really are similar yeah and The
Branding Vibes of both the companies are
going to be similar like Yellowstone CR
Wild West Ranch so same product same
branding honestly it's good grounds for
a legal fight it is what about the show
so does anybody care about the show
anymore no no I'm sorry the viewers care
deeply does anybody working on the show
give a rip want to give us a show no and
this is just another thing like bringing
us even further from a possible reunion
and getting back to work but rip should
be in the next iteration of Yellowstone
I think it's called like 20 24 or
whatever with Matthew mccon allegedly
yeah and so any future work between
Tyler I always just want to call her him
Tyler Taylor Sheridan and rip seems now
even less of a possibility which is
devastating so who side are you on I'm
always going to be on the side of Rip
but I'm not a judge and if I was a judge
I think I'd side with
Taylor
yeah and even if legally this has no
merit if I was Taylor Sheridan like I
would be annoyed on a personal level at
this guy who I made famous off of my
vibe and he then takes my vibe and
creates the same product as me yeah it's
you know what like it's not cool yeah
it's weird that's why I feel like
there's more to the story
like like maybe they wanted to start the
coffee company together and then Taylor
Sheridan kicked rip out and was like
[__] you I'm gonna do this myself and so
then Cole maybe he came up with the
original logo and he was like I'm gonna
do mine it kind of reminds me of like
Juliet and Kelsey from Siesta Key both
having a bikini line but they would have
been stronger together even though
Juliet being suine is doing really well
yeah but yeah better together
yeah this is so bizarre so bizarre I
just feel like there's more to the story
even though legally it looks like Taylor
has a slam dunk on his hands yeah
there's more to this story people don't
just like do stuff like this you're
right like I can't imagine Cole Houser
go to all this trouble to create this
brand and it's like a legit brand I keep
getting emails like from press releases
and wanting to send me gifting it's like
legit I can't imagine he would go to all
this trouble knowing it was like stolen
unless he had you know a good reason
yeah also can we talk about the fact
that I'm wearing
um what what do we call them big blue
jeans what big pants yeah like what do
we call it Big baggy jeans big baggy
pants I finally found a pair of jeans
that like I kind of like these are from
maidwell but can we talk about something
that nobody talks about with jeans like
the circulation to your vagina being cut
off like I'm in pain yeah I think maybe
uncross yeah definitely uncross but I'm
like a lady I see it like a lady but
between my underwear and this like tight
crotch and by the way don't be like get
a bigger pair no they fit really well
yeah don't come for me no super cool
jeans today I'm dressed like tury Jack
wearing my exact alph but I told you
I've been telling everyone stop sleeping
on Loft and that's from Loft I got a
bounty from Loft yesterday I was wearing
a super cute outfit before we um decided
not to do the show and I was actually
thinking about just wearing it
today but it's like I wanted to save it
for vacation I feel like if I wear it
again like I'm just ruining it so so I
think I found a solution to our problem
of like getting clothes for our vacation
and then wearing them and for me like
staining them before I even get a chance
or like washing them shrinking them you
know yeah no like the set that you're
wearing I got like two weeks ago for our
trip I've worn it five times Theo pooped
on it like it's literally useless to me
now um so I've every time I get
something new that I ordered for our
trip I'm putting it in a different
bedroom now it's all folded and it'll be
really easy to
pack I a gooda but it's like but we also
do a show every day where you like want
to wear something new cool and fresh so
it's like why am I saving this to go we
on a couch somewhere when I I'm on
camera no it's so true it's just maybe
maybe I'll take it out of the second
bedroom yeah and then wear bring it
still I the set that I wore yesterday
I'm not not going to wear it again
before vacation I'm glad I wore it
yesterday but now it's going straight to
Vacation yeah so maybe like a wear once
policy as a little treat love that get
it a little stretched out you know it
fits nice see how it
moves you ever get like a hair in your
lipstick of course we are women aren't
we I'm just a girl we're real women um
before we keep going you mind if I say
something of course I was hoping that
you would today's episode is brought to
you by lur l' Al the new L'Oreal Paris
bright reveal dark spot serum and
broadspectrum spf50 daily lotion you got
dark spots no you don't game over so
dark spots are just a part of life and
I'm realizing that as I get older we
need to be protecting our skin with SPF
every day under our makeup and on the
you know off chance you get a dark spot
know how to treat them thanks to L'Oreal
so L'Oreal paris's bright revealed dark
spot serum will visibly fade all types
of dark spots up to 40% so after 12
weeks they can show 40% less visibility
on post- acne marks 43% less visibility
on dark spots and 49% more even tone in
one week it can start fading even the
most stubborn dark spots and after two
weeks your skin will look clearer your
skin texture will look refined and
smooth it's made for all skin tones it's
suitable for sensitive skin and its
formula is validated by dermatologists
so that's the bright spot um dark spot
bright reveal serum but then you also
need a preventative measure an SPF to
wear under your makeup enter the bright
reveal SPF 50 daily UV lotion so you put
this on under your skin wearing SPF with
makeup I understand like is difficult
because a lot of them have bad texture
they make your makeup look weird they
leave a white cast not the L'Oreal one
it's lightweight and non- greasy it has
an invisible texture and it will blend
seamlessly with all of your all
different skin tones plus it primes well
with makeup so discover the new bright
revealed dark spots Duo visit Target
online and in store to buy yours today
today's episode is also brought to you
by Skylight frame looking for a
meaningful gift this holiday season that
your loved ones will actually use and
enjoy enter the Skylight frame
say goodbye to boring gifts and hello to
the Skylight frame which is perfect for
even the most hard to gift person so um
Sky life frame is a digital photo frame
it is the cutest most perfect holiday
gift for a partner a spouse a
grandparent what I love about it is that
even though it's technically technology
it's really easy to set up and you can
do all the work remotely by like sending
photos so get getting it for a parent or
a grandparent it's so sentimental but it
also doesn't require a lot of setup that
it's really perfect for someone even if
they're not like technologically
advanced like I am you know even if
they're not the IT department of their
toast it's a touchscreen photo frame
that you can send photos too straight
from your phone and they'll appear in
seconds you can even pre-load it before
the Box is open so again for a
grandparent making it really easy it's a
perfect gift for everyone new parents a
spouse a grandparent you can
effortlessly send photos to the frame
it's easy to use and the touchcreen
makes it really easy to swipe through
photos tap to see new photos it looks
beautiful in your home they have new
color options that match any style of
home so it's black white silver limited
edition Poppy and gold it's better than
social media it has totally thoughtful
features like the free app to send and
scroll through photos you can display
photos without Wi-Fi and they have
satisfaction guaranteed they are
confident that you'll love the Skylight
they offer 120-day free returns over a
million happy customers thousands of
five star reviews get yours and as a
special limited time offer for our
listeners get 15 bucks off your first
purchase of a skylight frame when you go
to skylightframe.com toast get $15 off
your purchase of a skylight frame when
you go to skylight frame.com toast
that's SK y l i g HTF R m.com toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by zbiotics maker of the world's first
genetically engineered probiotic so
zbiotics
pre-alert microbiologists zbiotics is a
prob probiotic drink that breaks down
the byproduct of alcohol which is
responsible for rough mornings after
drinking so this is a lifechanger buy it
okay have it in your house you will
thank me here's how it works have a
zbiotics for best results make sure to
have the zbiotics your be your first
drink of the night then drink
responsibly pace yourself hydrate get a
good night's sleep and then three enjoy
tomorrow wake up feeling refreshed and
ready to take on the day zbiotics is
just a fabulous product that actually
works I feel like this is one of the
most tough toughest things to crack
zbiotics works it's so good to just have
stock in your home it's a
genetically engineered probiotic just
remember to drink zbiotics before
drinking alcohol drink responsibly and
get a good night's sleep for your best
tomorrow so the first time I tried
zbiotics was before I went out to a
dinner with the tailor you know we all
know how those end as instructed I drank
a bottle of zbiotics before any alcohol
and I really was amazed how the next day
like I got up I went to work I felt okay
it really makes a difference so go to
zbiotics docomo to get 15% off your
first order when you use code toast at
checkout you can also sign up for
zbiotics subscription using our codes so
you can stay prepared no matter the time
or occasion it is backed with 100% money
back guarantee so if you're unsatisfied
for any reason they will refund your
money no questions asked remember to
head to zbiotics docomo use code toast a
checkout for 15% off thank you zbiotics
for sponsoring today's episode thank you
la you're welcome far our next story
some fun news probably would have been a
yesterday story Robert patson Suki
Waterhouse joined Taylor Swift in a
first joint appearance since pregnancy
new so a lot going on here Taylor went
out with Robert and Suki Suki and Robert
went out together Suki was burying the
bump the three of them had a jolly good
time and then there's the added element
of like what about Taylor lner you know
do you think that Taylor Swift was Team
Edward or Team Jacob in her Heyday I
think now she's Team Jacob I think she
was Team Edward because she's a romantic
and and he reads poetry and like that's
that's so tailor yeah no she is Team
Edward for sure I know I say this every
time but like I really am so happy for
Suki Waterhouse and Robert patson
despite my like insane jealousy and
honestly like if it couldn't be me and
it can't like I'm married and
unavailable so if it couldn't be me like
I'm really glad it's her I think they're
a really good match and they started
they really look alike to me in my mind
they look like siblings which I know is
the makings of a good couple yeah no I'm
just looking at some like couple picks
of them there aren't many but when they
are together they're so cute cute and I
think they're going to last forever I
hope they're going to last forever they
really are so cute they don't give us a
lot Public since I said that I need to
take it back otherwise because I'm wrong
about everything so I think it's not
going to last they're doomed they're no
no no Claudia they're not going to last
don't worry yeah yeah yeah but I love
them together they really publicly like
they give us nothing we have very few
moments of them I think like probably
the biggest most public display of like
affection that we have for them is from
the most recent maala where they looked
so happy and they were so well dressed
like I think these are two people who
are just really in love I think so too
and I love that I love love and so and
now they're hanging out with
Taylor do you know that they're all
friends yes they went to arist Tor LA
and I was like no way is Robert [__]
patson at the AOS Tor the AOS Tor to me
is just like the antithesis of
everything Robert patson like is cuz
he's so like artistic alternative like
mainstream sucks but that's just the
vibe that I give I'm sure he loves
Taylor's music you know Al it's like
he's in such mainstream things Twilight
Batman it's true actually you're kind of
like putting him in his box judging him
yeah but maybe I really see him as
Edward because like Edward wouldn't like
Taylor Swift you know what I mean I feel
like Edward would get
down oh also you know how our favorite
um statistic to share is like you had
once read they did like a Roundup of all
the the richest fictional characters
characters from books yes in TV movie
and books and Carlile was like number
one he's worth like $45 billion I saw
Tik Tok they like redid it and it's
actually unfair
because all of like the most rich
fictional TV characters are mostly
superheroes like if you take superheroes
out then it's still carile okay
superheroes and super villains there was
someone who was worth like way more
there were two people way worth way more
than but Bruce Wayne who I think is
Batman Robert hson was on theist too
he's worth 9
billion interesting yeah that's one of
did you take superheroes out of it which
I don't know why you would but if you
did carile would be number one I Carlile
Carlile like growing up is realizing
it's not Team Edward or Team Jacob it's
team Carlile it's team Carlile one cuz
he's so wealthy two he had such a good
head on his shoulders yeah and like he's
not that old because he's right no but
he's still hot and you know what this is
going to be a spoiler alert for the
final Twilight movie so if you haven't
seen it go away they really knew what
they were doing when they like fake
killed him off like they knew where it
would get the fans like remember like
where I was who I was like I remember my
stomach dropping I was literally in the
East Village I was an NYU student me and
Kristen went she had already seen it I
think so she like watched me watch that
I was gutted no like
flored knew what they wereing battle
scene I was just like the battles lost
like we spoiler alert lost Carlile and
then so for the the way that it ended to
be the way that it was the perfect
ending it was like I needed that so much
for it to be tabasa it was really the
perfect way to end that whole franchise
like they really left no stone unturned
there and they knew what they were doing
when they chose Carlile to be the one
who fake died and then they also knew
what they were doing bringing him
back bringing him back
you mean like wiping like the battle
never happened right yeah wait hold on I
hear music
too
down is that coming from the Street SE
so be that person's listening to music
really
loud oh yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah like I could never listen
to music that loud in my car cuz I'm
like a person who like cares about other
people you know no it's like I can't
think when so loud let alone drive and
not kill people can't see or drive it
needs to be at a even decibel I've
really been L the hell is that I've been
driving a lot by the way I feel like I
haven't been telling everyone every time
that I drive cuz it's just like so
casual for me this she's so regular like
I literally like drove into my golf cart
yesterday um but but there was no Mark
left on either so it's like it didn't
happen but I was being extremely dumb
nuts no not nuts cuz cuz I'm not nuts at
all I'm not a nuts person you're not
just dumb
like does it ever get easier it does I
just have to keep making these dumb
mistakes but most people like make them
at
16 yeah and I'm just but also every time
I do make do something really dumb it's
also kind of a relief it's like oh okay
I I have one dumb thing done like I feel
like I have to get the dumb things out
of my system you know and you never know
what they're going to be you never know
what they're going to
be are you okay I really like wasn't
listening no I could tell it's it's kind
of like happening more and
more been deal a lot I'm going give you
a past today I'll bring it up with you
on a different day cuz I was thinking
about the O were you yeah you know you
could like say that any time now I have
to shut up I
was you want to share no
okay I'll just cool I'll just keep my
personal anecdotes to myself for a while
no don't don't because they're listening
I just wasn't that's true let me know
when does it get easier and how many
dumb mistakes do I have to make before I
can drive with the clear conscience it
does get easier our fifth and final
story tur's Choice oh my God my breath
just smelled like Theo cuz my breath
like kind of smells bad I'm like
smelling in my
nose our fifth and final story was a
tury Choice it's a tury's choice choice
choice it's
a
choice at least we got you back to
singing yeah McDonald's is opening a new
chain called cosmics here are the
locations and menu McDonald said it's
opening a new chain called cosmics that
will focus on coffee and other drinks a
step that is viewed as a challenge to
Starbucks and Duncan as the fast food
giant seeks to boost afternoon sales
they opened its first cosmics location
in Illinois on Thursday with plans to
open additional restaurants in
2024 what's on cosmics menu the chain
will include new customizable drinks and
McDonald's favorites like the Egg
McMuffin the CEO noden let me say I have
a lot of thoughts on this and here's why
I wanted to talk about it I think this
is brilliant I actually really like the
name and I like The Branding and people
love Starbucks coffee and breakfast and
they're always mad it's literally in
movies like I didn't get here before
coffee and breakfast oh sorry sorry
sorry McDonald's people love their
coffees they love their breakfast and
it's like a limited people get mad when
they can't get it after a certain time
it's in the movie Big Daddy like it's a
part of the culture yeah so establishing
a whole franchise to it when that is a
proven success with like Starbucks and
dunan is brilliant also we're at a
really interesting inflection point with
Starbucks cuz I don't know if you know
this but like Starbucks is being um I
can never think of this word not
protested boycotted boycotted thank you
Starbucks is being boycotted and it's so
funny because if you ask like a Jewish
person like what their thoughts
politically on Starbucks are like they
love Starbucks but Starbucks like a
million years ago was like we will never
open uh franchises in Israel and that's
why the uh very popular chain Aroma
exists because it started in Israel it's
their Starbucks version now it's all
over the states I've been to one in
Canada so like a pro- Israel person
would be like [__] Starbucks but prop
Palestine people hate Starbucks because
during in the aftermath of October 7th a
bunch of uh
employees I think at like one location
like wrote a letter and put up Flags or
whatever and Starbucks was like this is
actually really insensitive after
thousands of Jews were just killed in
Israel like not now please it was like
the Starbucks Union or something yeah
but it's like so pro Israel people were
mad about the Starbucks Union writing
this disgraceful letter so pro-israel
people are boycotting Starbucks because
their employees Harbor these views and
then the Starbucks corporate kind of
like shut down the letter so Pro
Palestine people are mad at Starbucks
for shutting down letter so like they've
kind of have no they can only have they
have no fans who are not who don't care
about the conflict I'm on Tik Tok and
people are like like showing their their
support for Palestine by drinking a
Duncan like so Starbucks is having like
a really they're going to it from all
ends no for sure Zach used to like Bring
me um an egg bite from Starbucks cuz he
likes to go to Starbucks and then that
letter was circulated I'm like don't
bring me Starbucks anymore right
everyone has an issue with Starbucks
they like you know they tried to
distance thems from the letter but one
the damage was done two those egg bites
aren't filling and I don't need the
calories so it was best for me so I
think this cosmics launch is actually an
people are literally looking for a new
Starbucks no but McDonald's is also
being protested by free Palestine oh
you're right because Israeli Starbucks
Israeli McDonald's was giving free meals
to Israelis and maybe War because even
in London like some free Palestine
person was freeing Palestine by um spray
painting a bunch of rats and releasing
them into McDonald you're right so
they're protesting McDonald's too damn
well I do think this is a great idea
that's what I was trying to say okay I
think it's a great idea too because I
love food I love beverages I love food
and beverages I like McDonald's a lot
and I just want to give some suggestions
for things that I would like to see at
cosmics if on the menu on the menu
because I'm not you know a sausage egg
and cheese type of girly but there are
two one we need egg vites Starbucks has
them on Lock and McDonald's I think you
could do it better I really do
egg bites two the thing from Duncan that
I love those egg and cheese breakfast
wraps I need more breakfast options low
calorie egg white you know egg white
muffin egg bites egg white breakfast
wraps maybe a breakfast taco breakfast
burrito little love these are some
things I could get behind and of course
make the coffee tasty so can they they
released their menu can you share can we
talk about what's going on at Panera
I don't know what's going on in Panera
let's finish this thought first the
chain will include new customizable
drinks as we said also make sure you get
all sugarfree flavors you know
sugar-free vanilla sugar-free haut we
could go hard with the sugar-free iced
coffee yeah but is McDonald's trying to
become like a diety place McDonald's is
not known for sorry I'm talking about my
needs yeah no I know but I also feel
like dieting girlies like they love a
customizable sugar-free beverage they do
so I'm just telling you about like this
sect but there are other needs out there
but it seems like they also will have a
churro frap a s'mores cold brew a what
cold brew
s'mores is it sugar-free oh my God who
cares who wants a s'mores cold brew a
500 calorie drink to start the day not
me a lot of people a lot of people not
me okay a lot of people too um they'll
also sell non- coffee beverages
including a sour cherry energy burst
yuck oh kind of sounds like they're
coming for Sonic too they're coming for
everyone even the name Cosmic is kind of
sonicypablo
was like this is them coming for
Starbucks Starbucks Starbucks it sounds
more like they're coming for Sonic they
will also include customizations
including popping
Boba wow flavor syrups just make sure
they're sugar-free in there oh yeah and
energy and vitamin C shots coming for
Aran as well wait I think this is
brilliant I really do I think it's
brilliant too please open One in New
York or Florida and tury and I will do a
dedicated mcbang to cosmics We Will We
Will oh they did say where they're
opening next hold hold on let me just go
back to that um The Branding was so
retro I actually I loved like the way
the aesthetic everything it looked
really great it opened to the public on
Thursday located off Weber Road in
Bowling Brook Illinois and then they
also have a Texas location as well
McDonald's plans to open about 10,000
new stores worldwide by 2027 also so
these are different like locations
physical locations than McDonald's it's
not just like the cosmics menu no no no
it's like a full different store that's
cly crazy too cuz I feel like they could
have just beefed up their breakfast at
McDonald's yeah no this is Major it's
major we're getting like a major new
fast food chain that has the resources
to be everywhere all at once and not
have to like build up regionally first
exactly now Panera I don't know if you
saw they released a new product it's
like a Charged lemonade like really
caffeinated two people have
died and that's unacceptable how much
caffeine like a lot like I think it
caused heart failure for some people I
want to just know like what levels of
caffeine so Panera caffeine
beverage damn rip I
know Panera caffeine lemonade cited
another wrongful death
lawsuit 390 milligrams of
caffeine whoa another paner page listed
it as 235 milligrams of caffeine 74 gram
of sugar damn that's why I'm harping on
the sugar-free turty 100 % it's it's a
safety precaution yeah who knew 235
milligrams of caffeine is even is fatal
it's like it's a lot of caffeine to
drink all at once but to be
fatal there's more to story pre-existing
conditions there's more pre there's more
of the story there always it's been a
bad week for
Panera that's our
show I feel
better I'm glad what are you going to
have for lunch on a brighter note I've
I've made some plans I don't want to go
home like home is really depressing and
I had literally canceled my entire week
so I have like no work to do so I'm
going to go out to lunch where you going
to go well I guess don't tell me cuz if
you're there and then I'm going to go
shopping okay and I'm just going to like
you know I'm going to spend my day
you're having a girly day yeah maybe
I'll get like a manicure or something
I'm just going to treat myself that's
beautiful so thank you to everyone for
listening and thank you for just all the
lovely messages knowing that Theo
touched so many people and he got to
meet so many people we brought him to
Camp toast he was just always walking on
the street people would always send me
pictures being like I think I saw Theo
and butters like he was really kind of
like a New York socialite I think um a
lot of people would see him that way so
I really appreciate the messages I'm
going to get to all of them like I'm I'm
not in the mood to read them right now
it just makes me really sad but thank
you and yeah that's our show d t more
music what song is it now is it a
message from d
hop everyone dancing merrily in the new
fash thank you guys so much for
listening to the toast Monday Morning
Show where we delal with the past five
stories you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so watching us
on YouTube please to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available podcast podcast be found
sptify
podcast a beautiful setting and weekly
downed we are have an amazing
day we'll see you next week have a good
weekend we love you dearly love you
dearly
bye